OUT IN
COZENS BACK-AND-FORTH AND JEFF
SKINNER FROM THE ACROSS ICE.
TAPPED TO THE CORNER. MARK PYSY
COMING OUT O O BACK IN THE OTHE
DIRECTION, TRYING TO KICK IT
FREE, HAYDEN GETS IN FRONT FOR
COULDN'T QUITE REACH IT.ORE!
THAT ONE HARD ENOUGH TO SQUEAK
THROUGH, RIGHT ON TD THE BUFFAL
NET AND KNOCKED AWAY NOW, THE P
HIS LONG SHOT, HE SCORED, DRILL
GOAL OF THE
THEY SCOOOORE!!
THERE IT I I GET
HIS 14th ON THE YEAR, 4th ON
JOKIHARJU WOUND UP AND
THERE, GOES OFF KREBSSKINNER.
FOR TUCH.
GETS T
PEYTON KREBS, YOU ARE HAV
TO GET THEIUM  JUMP
AND PHILLY WILL SEND IT ON TO
CENT
GETS CHECKED.
GETS IT RIGHT BACK AGAIN.
TAMARKOVIC, THE  A
HERE'S DAHLIN, SETS HIM UP ON
THAT
THAT'S YOUR FAULT,  GOES
BACK TO KONECNY, HE JUST FIRES
THIS ONE THROUGH AND THAT IS